[Music]
one of the first things I want to do
before we get into the presentation
proper is I want to demonstrate
something that's I'm gonna quickly
introduce it right now and then towards
the end of the session we're gonna
circle back around and make more sense
of it but there are some reasons that
I'll clarify later that I want to kick
this off right now and if we could
switch to the demo machine briefly that
would help me out all right so as I said
I'm going to demonstrate something
really quickly that's only gonna make a
little bit of sense right now and we're
gonna make it make more sense before
we're done but I've got a couple of
micro-services running out on GCP right
now and notice the URL there begins with
MN - backend so I'm sending a request to
this back-end service and I'm sending a
request to slash hello slash Jeff is all
that's really important about that URL
slash hello slash Jeff and we get back a
response that is what you see there
hello space Jeff that doesn't look
terribly interesting but there are a
number of interesting things going on
that we'll get to so when I send a
request to the back-end service at /l o
slash Jeff we get a response like you
see there and if I send a similar
request to another service called the
front-end service what we're gonna see
is a similar response but the response
is all uppercase and and all what we've
got in place is there are two micro
services deployed to GCP right now one
is the back-end service one is the
front-end service the back-end service
knows how to create this greeting hello
Jeff the front-end service is calling
the backend service and converting the
message to uppercase just we've got
something happening in the front-end
service that's really all I want to get
into around that what those services are
capable of right now but what I want to
do while I'm pressing into the rest of
the of the talk is I want to deploy a
new version of this back-end service and
that's going to allow me to talk about
some interesting capabilities that's
that I think you'll find interesting so
I've just made a code change to our
back-end controller there where it says
a moment ago it said hello plus name
that's the service this is the service
we're invoking from the command line I'm
going to make a code change and
instead of saying hello Jeff it'll say
Google max it says hello Jeff and I want
to deploy that at that service to GCP
have the engine deployed just like that
and I'll let that get far enough along
that I know that I don't have a typo
there that looks good
okay so while that's running if we can
go back to the slides now I appreciate
the help
we're gonna come back to that and talk
about a number of interesting things
going on there all right so my name is
Jeff Brown I am a partner at object
computing and I'm one of the cofounders
of a couple of open source frameworks
that we develop and support one of them
is the Grails framework which is a JVM
web framework that's been around for
over a decade and it's been tremendously
successful and we're very proud of that
and I'm also the co-founder of another
technology called micro knot which I'm
going to spend more time talking about
today I helped run the Grails and micro
not practice it's an object computing
and you see some contact information
there amazing enough to track down if
you want to get a hold of me and
speaking of getting a hold of me we do
have a booth set up out here in the
exhibit hall the booth number is on the
very last slide so that'll be easy
enough for you to find later I believe
it's 1163 please stop by the booth if
you have and talk to us if you have any
questions at all about what I'm going to
introduce today or anything at all that
we can help you with all right so object
computing is headquartered in st. Louis
Missouri which is where I happen to live
we are a distributed team we've got
folks all over the country and elsewhere
we've got a number of folks in Europe
and Australia but our headquarters is in
st. Louis and as they said that's where
I happen to live object computing has
been in business for about 25 years and
has been an open source company since
the very beginning which is really
interesting on part because in the mid
90s there were not very many open source
companies and object computing was one
of them
we heard some great talk this morning
during the keynote about Google's
commitment to open source and I'll get
back to that point a little bit later in
the presentation but we've done some
really interesting things with Google
that relates to our open source software
and and I'll get to that
so object computing is the home to both
the Grails and micronaut team it's
really one big team we don't have to
separate teams managing these two
technologies it's one team of engineers
and as I said I'm the practice Lee there
at a drop you object computing helping
manage all of those efforts we've got
deep expertise in a number of areas some
of them that you see listed there
industrial IOT machine learning
blockchain consulting and cloud
engineering we're gonna find that most
of you are probably aware that Google is
a great fit GCP in particulars are great
fit for building these kinds of
applications and Micra not is a really
great fit for building these kinds of
applications and deploying them to GCP
and i'm gonna spend some time this
morning pressing in to some details that
will support all of that and help that
make helped that make more sense this is
a partial list of clients at object
computing some of these companies some
of these names we saw earlier during the
keynote as some of these companies are
large Google Google users one of the
interesting things about this this
partial client list is notice that it
spans really a lot of of industries
we've got the semiconductors
telecommunications finance aerospace so
object computing has served many
industries over the last 25 years and it
turns out that's a great fit for what I
want to talk about today because Micra
not and GCP these are not technologies
for aerospace and they're not
technologies for telecommunications
they're general-purpose technologies
that can be used everywhere and that's
just one more reason that that our
technology and GCP is such a great fit
together and by the way I cannot see
past the first few rows in a room this
room this big so raising your hand will
not help I probably won't see your hand
I'll try to make some time for Q&A at
the end and there are mics here where
we'll take those questions if we do have
time but as I said at the beginning if
you've got any questions at all that we
don't get get to today please come by
the booth and see us I intended to
mention that earlier apologize for that
all right
so I mentioned just really really
quickly I want to talk a little bit
about the Grails framework and then I
want to get into micronaut and GCP but
talking just just for a couple of
minutes about grilles is going to help
us make sense of some of the stuff that
I want to press into so grills is an
open source framework for building web
applications for the JVM and it's been
around for over a decade in February of
2008 is when we shipped Grails 1.0 and
the framework predates one dot o by a
year or so
so the frameworks been around for 11 or
12 years will save and it's been
tremendously successful over that time
so we're very proud of the girls
framework and the the business that we
have built around that one of the things
that has enabled Grails to be as
relevant as and as important as it's
been for as long as it has been for over
a decade is the fact that the technology
has evolved considerably since the
beginning to stay relevant to the way
that folks want to build applications
today so in 2007 when we started all of
this rest was certainly the idea of rest
existed but it was nowhere near as big
of a deal as it is today every
enterprise builds rest services today
and so in the very beginning there
wasn't a whole lot of support for rest
in in the Grails framework you could
certainly build rest services with
Grails but there wasn't a whole lot of
support for building those kinds of apps
and over the years as rest got more and
more important Grails stayed ahead of
that by adapting to the way that people
want to build applications so over the
years we built more and more support for
publishing rest services and today we
have really really terrific supporting
Grails for building rest services and
that's an example of the technology
evolving over the years to stay relevant
and that's an important part of the
technologies longevity Gorem falls in
that same category Gorham is the orm
tool that's part of Grails and it's
always been part of Grails it's been
part of Grails since the very beginning
and in the very beginning Gorham was
really just a lair it was conceived to
be a layer on top of hibernate we added
a bunch of really cool and powerful
capabilities on top of hibernate and
made it easier to take advantage of what
hibernate had to offer but that's what
Gorham was in the
very beginning and then over the years
Gorham has evolved to adapt to the way
that people want to use the technology
like corn so for example early on we
introduced JP a support so you could
pull out hibernate and plug in whatever
JP a implementation you like and then
fast forward a few years past that and
the so called no SQL databases started
gaining a lot of traction and momentum
databases like MongoDB and Cassandra and
there were there were a whole bunch of
those people wanted to use Gorham to
talk to those kinds of databases so we
evolved Gorm further and today we've got
Gorham implementations for hibernate and
JPA and MongoDB and neo4j which is a
really interesting graph database
Cassandra we've got a bunch of Gorham
implementations the point there is that
the technology has evolved to stay
relevant and to keep itself in an
important part of the landscape and in
which these these technologies these
play
so as we're confronted with changes in
the landscape the technology changes to
deal with those and now today and in
recent years one of the changes that
we've had to confront and and come up
with solutions for a whole category of
challenges is microservices right when
we first started building grilles a
decade ago monoliths were the way that
most folks built and deployed JVM web
applications right you put your whole
application in one big war file drop
that war file in Tomcat or whatever
server container you prefer and that's
how you deploy deploy web applications
and if any part of that application
needs to be updated you really you have
to update the whole thing and there
there are benefits to a monolithic
architecture like that there are
drawbacks to a monolithic architecture
like that but that's how applications by
and large were built and that those are
the kinds of applications that Grylls
was initially a design for and
prioritized for now as more and more
enterprises want to build micro service
architectures there's a whole suite of
challenges that come along with building
those kinds of systems and that's
another example of changes in the
landscape that our technology needs to
needs to adapt to so we recognized
those changes those new challenges
Google recognizes those those challenges
and and and you recognize those
challenges or you will as you start
looking into migrating to micro service
architectures there are lots of good
reasons to deploy applications and that
kind of architecture but it's not all
all the benefits don't come for free
right there there are new challenges
that you'll have to confront with micro
services that maybe you didn't have to
confront with with with monoliths and
what we're doing with micro not and our
integrations with GCP is we're trying to
make it as easy as possible for folks to
build those kinds of systems and take
advantage of these really robust
services that Google has to offer
with minimal burden on the application
development team and minimal complexity
in the the application code base so we
recognized that this a whole new set of
challenges that relate to micro services
and we had to decide what to do about
that so when we wanted to evolve ghorm
we realized hey we've got this great
tool for dealing with relational
databases people want to use that some
of the they want to use that tool to
talk to non-relational databases and we
figured out how to evolve the technology
to deal with that with micro services we
that was one of our options right well
one of the things we could have done was
continue to evolve our current
technology to be more and more
compatible with the way that are more
and more compatible with with micro
service architectures that that's one
approach we could we could have taken we
decided not to take that approach rather
than evolve our current technology to be
a better fit for micro services what we
decided to do was design a whole new
thing from the ground up specifically
designed for micro services and
specifically prioritizing micro service
architectures and that's what micro not
is micro not is an open source framework
for building micro service applications
for the JVM it's been designed and
optimized specifically for micro
services so certainly you can build
monoliths with micro not and people will
do that and people have success with
that but we're designing an Optima
the framework specifically for for
microservice architectures the runtime
is very lightweight it's based on Neddie
which offers a bunch of really positive
characteristics it's really fast it's
really lightweight it's got a bunch of
really great reactive support in the
framework that we're taking advantage of
at the micronaut level so the runtime in
micro nan is based on nettie and as they
said it's really really fast and really
really lightweight well we'll come back
to that point a little bit later micro
not is a polyglot framework so the
languages that we've got proper support
for in micro not include Java Kotlin and
groovy and all of our annotation
processing that we all the annotations
that we support in micro not work across
all three of those languages the exact
same annotations they all yield the same
net effects so if you would prefer to
build your systems with kopplin and you
prefer to take advantage of all the
benefits that Conklin has to offer you
can do that and take advantage of
everything that micronaut has to offer
if you prefer dynamic languages like
groovy we've got terrific support for
doing that if you're a Java shop and
don't want to introduce any of these
other non Java jvm languages you can
build your whole systems with Java and
the languages can mix and match within a
project so within a single micro
non-service you can have Java code and
Kotlin code and groovy code and it all
just plays well together really really
well so it's a polygon framework for the
JVM micro knot is really not just one
thing it's it's a really a whole
portfolio of things and that portfolio
of things includes some components like
an aspect-oriented programming engine
and a dependency injection container and
an HTTP client and a number of these
components can be used separate from the
rest of Micra not so for example our
dependency injection container that we
built in micro not has some really
interesting innovative characteristics
to it that I'll talk about
but that di container is usable separate
from the rest of my chronometer so if
you're building a java application and
you want a DI container you can use
micronauts di container in that java
application without using any of our
HTTP server stuff or without using any
of the other components
that are part of that are part of Micra
not which is great some of the
interesting characteristics of our
dependency injection container all have
to do with the fact that our di
container doesn't do any runtime
reflection which it turns out is a
really big deal one of the reasons that
our that our current technology before
we built micro not so Grails in
particular one of the reasons that
Grails is not a terrific fit for
building micro services has to do with
Grails dependence on the spring
framework and the spring framework is
terrific there's all kinds of really
really great stuff that spring does and
and those are the reasons that we built
Grails on top of the spring framework
but spring is expensive in some ways for
certain kinds of applications and a lot
of that has to do with Springs
dependence on runtime reflection and
dynamic proxies so what we've done with
Mike Renaud is we've eliminated all the
runtime reflection and all the runtime
proxies and replace that with really
sophisticated ahead of time compilation
compiled time tricks to do all the stuff
that we otherwise would have done with
reflection at runtime so all of our
annotation processing is all configured
at compile time our whole dependency
injection container is all configured at
compile time
no runtime proxies no runtime reflection
and that is where a lot of our
performance benefits are coming from the
Micra not and where a lot of other
positive aspects like much smaller
memory footprints so we'll talk talk a
little bit more about that as we press
are as I said Mike Renaud is is being
designed and optimized specifically for
building micro services and in a micro
service architecture you don't have one
thing you have numerous things and maybe
lots of things right you have this whole
architecture of components communicating
with each other so our request comes
into the system and hits component a and
component a calls component B and
component B calls component C and that's
how these micro service architectures
work in each one of those interactions
you've got a client and a server right
when a calls B a is the client and B as
a server and when B calls C B becomes a
client and C us the server for that
particular communication because that's
the way a micro service architecture
work micronaut prioritizes both sides of
those communications so we've got a
really really sophisticated HTTP client
as well as a bunch of really cool and
powerful server-side stuff and we'll
look at examples of both of those some
of the priorities that the framework
have has include things like a developer
productivity time to market is really
important and really valuable and we
recognize that so we make a lot of
design decisions specifically targeted
at contributing to developer
productivity and another attribute that
goes along with that is code simplicity
in a micronaut application you're going
to write considerably less code than you
might with other frameworks and all that
is is related to not only time to market
but ease of maintaining and extending
the system over time so we prioritize
developer productivity and code
simplicity while embracing a familiar
programming model so folks who are used
to building applications with modern JVM
web frameworks will see a lot of the
same kinds of idioms show up in a micro
nod application so for example you can
write a service class and annotate that
service class with at transactional and
a bunch of really cool and powerful
transaction management related stuff
will be associated with that class that
what I just now described isn't new and
isn't innovative that those capabilities
have been around for a long time
but how we're doing that is new and
innovative and again that that has to do
with all of our compile time annotation
processing stuff which allows us to rig
up things like the DI container all at
compile time and not rely on any runtime
reflection or runtime practices and a
particularly important part of all this
that that we want to focus on today is
our ease of integration with with these
really really sophisticated enterprise
scale type cloud services so if you're
gonna build a micro service architecture
and deploy at the GCP you're probably
going to want to take advantage of
things like cloud SQL and kubernetes and
all of these robust services that Google
has has has provided one of the things
that Mike Renaud is doing is making it
very very
easy to take advantage of those services
without having to take on much of the
burden or the cost associated with the
development burdens associated with what
building systems that take advantage of
those services and the framework is
really really fast run time performance
is another one of the things that's an
important attribute of it affects all of
our design decisions so we want you to
be able to build the thing quickly we
want it to be simple easy to maintain
and easy to extend code we want you to
be able to integrate with these robust
suite of cloud services that are out
there and we need the thing to be really
really fast
at runtime and and in fact it is so some
of the important benefits that that
micronaut has to offer include runtime
performance that shows up in terms of
startup time for your services as well
as performance while the application is
running so a micro not a typical
microdots service can be started up in
something like a second some sometimes
less than a second sometimes a little
bit more depends on what what the
application is doing but a second put
you in the neighborhood it's not like 20
seconds or 30 seconds or even 10 seconds
one second startup time put put you in
and put you in the ballpark minimal
memory requirement so a small micro not
service can run and about 10 megabytes
of heap and depending on what your
application is doing will dictate how
much above that you need but that kind
of represents the overhead or the tax
associated with the framework itself
which is really really quite small we'll
look at we're not going to look at a
whole lot of code here today but we'll
see a little bit of code but one of the
one of the attributes of systems built
with micro knot is the code really is
quite simple as they said before we're
embracing familiar programming models
and embracing or enabling easy
integration with with cloud services so
a small micro not jar file might be
about 8 megabytes of that's the size of
the jar file and of course the more code
you put in your project the jar file is
going to get bigger but that again
represents kind of the the overhead that
the framework brings along which is
really quite small and you see the
startup time and heap requirement
numbers there and I want to take just a
minute
talk a little bit about these these are
attributes that relate to microservices
in ways that they don't necessarily
relate to monolithic applications so
think about memory consumption as an
example if you're building a monolithic
application and that application
requires a gig of RAM to run in your
development environment you start the
thing up by whatever with Gradle or
whatever tool you're using to start the
start the app and you allocate a gig of
ram to the thing or maybe the startup
scripts are doing that for you and you
don't even really think about it but
allocating a gig of ram to your
monolithic app may not be that big of a
deal because there's only one of them in
a micro service architecture there's not
going to be one of them there's going to
be maybe lots of them so try to start if
you've got a monolithic servlet
container based a web app and try to
start say 30 of those up concurrently on
your development machine and it's just
not going to work for a number of
reasons and one of those reasons is
you're gonna run into to memory memory
issues in a micro service architecture
you might really want to do that you
might want to start up a whole bunch of
services on one machine in your
development environment so the memory
requirements become a factor into that
equation differently than they would for
a monolithic application and in your
deployment environment on the cloud
where you're paying for VMs that based
on how many CPUs and how much RAM you're
allocating to them adding up all of
those large memory requirement machines
in your cloud environment can get
expensive so these are examples of
attributes that manifest differently or
they affect your micro service
architectures differently than they
affect monolithic applications so
micronaut embraces one of the things
that micron does is it makes it very
very easy to take advantage of these
robust cloud services that the cloud
providers make available so we've got
really really great support for service
discovery by way of council we've got
support for Eureka we've got support for
kubernetes which so we support all the
major service discovery engines and this
again this is an
example of a thing that's important in a
micro service application that's not
important or maybe not even relevant at
all in the context of a monolithic
application if in a model if there's
only one so there is no discovery right
you're not going out and trying to find
these other things to communicate with
so service discovery is is an example of
a capability that the framework provides
to make it easy to take advantage of
something like service discovery that is
part of that new suite of challenges
that micro service architectures bring
along configuration sharing is kind of
the same thing if you've got lots of
micro services to point out in your
cloud environment you probably want them
to share configuration and we've built
really really sophisticated systems to
make it easy to take advantage of
distributed configuration engines and
all the major cloud providers we've got
some really interesting client-side load
balancing stuff built into our HTTP
client that if I've got some time I'll
be able to demonstrate it's a little bit
later we've got support for building
message driven applications we've got
integrations with technologies like
Kafka we've got really great support for
service computing and a lot more right
so the the micro nod is not just a
framework for building rest services
right it's not just with just that it is
that but it's a whole bunch more than
that and a lot of that has to do with
all of these cloud native capabilities
that we've built right into the
technology this quote here that was
posted on Twitter I believe this was
posted before we even got to release one
dotto which we released this past
October this person recognized something
that what he's recognizing is that one
of the things that Mike Renaud is and
does is it enables you to very easily
build these systems that take advantage
of all these services like Kafka and
console and Zipkin and MongoDB and JPA
and on and on that's one of the things
that Mike Renaud is is it's an enabler -
it's an accelerator for folks who want
to take advantage of these robust cloud
services without having to spend lots of
time and development effort building the
integrations with those with those
systems so Google has been a priority
for for the micronaut team at object
computing really pretty much the whole
time that we've been work
on this but certainly right now Google
Google is a priority we've partnered
with Google object competing as an
official Google partner and we've got
really great support in Micra not for
taking advantage of GCP Google cloud
services so we've got support for
kubernetes and stackdriver and G RPC and
there are others some of these Google's
actually contributed the support to the
framework too so for example this week
we'll be releasing micronaut 1.1 and in
1.1 we've got some news support for
stackdriver in G RPC and some of that
was developed by Google and they
contributed those those efforts to to
the open source software which is
fantastic and that that's a little bit
of putting your money where your mouth
is with respect to what Google said this
morning during the keynote google says
that they're committed to open source
and Google really is committed to open
source and this is one small way that
that that manifests right so I want to
take a look and a little bit of code and
that'll help us tease out some things
that I think you'll find interesting so
this could be a Java class in a in a
micronauts service and does we've got a
controller what makes this thing a
controller is it's annotated with that
controller those of you who might be
familiar with the Grails framework might
recognize that in Grails we have lots of
conventions in place that do things like
if you've got a class whose name ends in
the word controller it becomes a
controller and those conventions do not
exist in the micronaut framework so what
makes this a controller is not the class
name the class name could be anything
what makes it a controller is its
annotated with that controller and
there's a method in this controller
that's annotated with that get so if I
send a get request to slash hello slash
something this controller action gets
executed and then I can do whatever I
need to do and there's a lot I could do
in this controller there's a bunch of
interesting data marshalling going on in
both directions for reading and writing
the body and of the request and the
response there's a bunch of reactive
stuff there's a whole lot you can do in
the controller this example is is a
literally a whole world kind of kind of
example but that that's a controller
that could be in a in a micro not
service and in fact the service that I
was interacting with from the command
line at the very beginning of the
session looked a whole lot like that
right so we've got this back-end
application that has a controller in it
but I might have another service this is
not in the same application this is a
whole different service that that's part
of our micro service architecture this
is the front end right so I've got a
back-end piece that's maybe talking to a
database and doing whatever it's doing
and separate from that I've got another
micro service that is in the in the
front end and this thing needs to call
or once to call on the backend service
that's how micro service architectures
work you've got these components making
calls to each other this is one Micro
not this is one micro service making a
call to another and the call is
happening at that last line of code
there where it says back-end client dot
hello name that's actually making an
HTTP call to some other service and
there are a number number of interesting
things going on in that method call and
we're gonna be able to press into just a
little bit of that notice that back-end
client that we're interacting with there
was injected into this controller by way
of dependency injection and so we've got
a constructor here called that accepts a
back-end client as a parameter and at
compile time
micronaut will recognize that that
constructor is there and create all the
instructions that it takes to create not
only create this thing but to pass the
required dependencies as constructor
parameters when it is created so the
backend client is being injected into
this controller and that's one of the
things I want to look at and this is the
backend client and this looks terribly
benign right there's really nothing
interesting that's apparent from looking
at that source code it's not even a
class it's just an interface that has a
method in it and there are a couple of
annotations as uninteresting as the
source code looks what's actually going
on is quite interesting so at compile
time what the framework is doing is
creating an instance of creating a class
that implements this interface and in
that class will be a method called hello
and when you call that method an HTTP
request will be made to some remote
service and we'll fit we'll figure out
how we how
no about where that remote services
before we're done but we're making an
HTTP call to some remote service and
passing so if I call hello and past Jeff
as a parameter
then the request will be sent to slash
hello slash Jeff all right so we've made
it very very easy to make an HTTP call
but this is more than just that so when
I annotated this interface with at
client that's what makes this thing an
HTTP client and the value that I can
specify there it can be one of a number
of things so where you see back-end URL
inside of the curly braces that's a
variable it's a config variable so
whatever the value of back-end URL is
that that'll be inserted at this point
so instead of using a config variable I
could put a URL there I can put HTTP
colon slash slash and have a URL there
and now when I make calls to this method
that URL represents where the remote
services that I'll be communicating with
and there are other values that that
backend URL could have but let's let's
press on here so now I've got some
configuration in the backend and the
front-end represented here the remember
these are two separate services two
separate applications we'll say in my
development environment I want to be
able to run these things concurrently I
want to be able to run the backend and
run the front-end and because of that
they need to run on different ports so
in my back-end config file I've
configured the thing to run on port 8080
to in the front-end config file I
haven't specified what port I wanted to
run on so by default it'll run on port
8080 so now when I start these things up
the back end is on 8080 to the front end
is on 8080 and the value of back-end
that URL is what you see in this config
file localhost 8080 - so the config file
on the right is in the front end project
and that's the front end project being
told where the backend services the
backend service is on localhost 8080 -
and that works fine in my development
environment but what what about when I
deploy this to GCP my back-end service
is not going to be running on localhost
8080 - it's gonna be running someplace
else so these are the config files that
I would
have my in my project that support my
development environment in addition to
those application demo files you can
have config files with names like
application - GCP demo now that that -
GCP means something special - micro not
so these config files will only be
loaded if the application is running on
GC P so if I if I run these applications
in my development environment these
configs are in place when I build those
those applications and deploy them to GC
p these configs are in place in addition
to the application DM will configs and
these settings take take precedence so
in the backend service I've got
application - tcp configured so the
service runs on port 8080 which would be
the default value had i not changed that
in the config file there on the left
remember I set that to 8080 to for the
benefit of my development environment
when I deployed GCP I want that config I
want that service to run on port 8080 so
I've got a supporting config there and
likewise in the front-end when I'm
running on GC P that's where the backend
service is running is that URL that you
see there so instead of looking at
localhost 8080 - we're looking at the
URL that you see there that's where the
front end will be making calls - to get
data from the backend right and this is
one small example of support in the
framework specifically targeted at a GC
P and here I'm just configuring a port
number and a URL but all of your
application configure your application
config that needs to be different in in
that environment in the cloud
environment GCP cloud environment in
particular those we provided a place for
you to put those those configs right so
now I'm ready to publish these
applications to GCP and so I've got a
couple of app demo files the URL down
there at the bottom gives you the full
reference for all the things you can do
in these FMO files I've kept these
really really simple
so on the left is the back-end service
on the right is the front-end service
and I think they're configured exactly
the same except for the service names so
I've got some auto scaling in place
there we can configure how much RAM is
being allocated each of these each of
these environments but I've got config
files for both the services is what's
relevant there and now one of the last
pieces is one of the ways to deploy
micro nod services to to TCP is you can
use Google's App Engine Gradle plugin
which is really really simple to use
right so I add it to the class pass of
the build script as you see up in the
upper left apply the plug-in and then
down at the bottom left you see where
I'm configuring some things that the App
Engine plugin needs
so in particular I have to specify where
is the jar file that is the application
that I wanted to play when I run the
deploy I want to stop the previous
version I want to promote the new one to
automatically become the kind of the
main one and project OCI micronaut
that's just the name of the project
where I'm deploying these things so if
we were to yeah so if I were to execute
the app engine deploy Gradle task the
command you see on the right there
that's literally what I would type in to
deploy this service to GCP in fact that
is what I typed in at the beginning of
the service at the beginning of the of
the presentation to deploy a new version
of our back-end service to GCP so I've
added just a few lines of code to the
build that Gradle file executed a Gradle
command and that service has has been
deployed the GCP and we'll get back to
that a little bit we'll see the new
version of the service responding to
requests but again what I wanted to
point out here is how easy it is to
deploy micronaut services to GCP just a
few lines in your build build Gradle
file a similar sort of roughly a similar
amount of code would be involved in
doing the same thing with maven
micronaut has great support for both
Gradle and maven really you can use any
build tool that you like but we've made
it very very easy to deploy applications
to GCP and one more example of GCP
specific config is in addition to
application yamo you can express your
micro not config in executable groovy
code and now you can have arbitrary
logic in your config file for for
generating config values and in this
particular case
reaching out to Google's metadata server
to grab some secrets about my database
URL my database username my database
password so this is code that I can
commit to source code control there's no
passwords there's no secrets here this
code only gets evaluated when the
applications running on GCP and when the
application is running on GCP I'm
getting all my database credentials from
the metadata server there you've got a
lot of flexibility there
Micra not is great it really as a
component of many parts of your
application architecture so the easy one
to think about is micro-services writes
people build micro-services they
deployed them to GCP and Mike Renaud is
terrific for that but Mike Renaud is
also a great fit for certain kinds of
edge devices so I've got a bunch of
raspberry PI's here that in just a
minute I'll spend a couple minutes
talking about what's going on there but
we've got Mike Renaud services running
on these raspberry PI's doing some
interesting things I have Mike ranaut
code running on an Android phone so I've
got a Google pixel 3 and I've got some
micro services deployed to GCP I've got
micro not application running on my
phone a native app running on the phone
built with micro not that's making calls
to those TCP services these particular
edge devices are not making calls to GCP
but they've very well could so we've got
really really great integration support
in micro not for participating in a
number of areas of your architecture so
it could be the case that you've got
micro not apps running on your edge
devices you've got micro nod services
running on your cloud environment you
could have micro not apps running on
mobile devices and we've got there
attributes of the framework that make
its are really really compelling in all
those environments and I'm gonna press
on here and try to get straight to some
demos so if we could switch back to the
demo machine that would be helpful
there we go so that's a picture for
those of you who are far away and can't
really see that's a picture of this
thing right so what I've got is I've got
four Raspberry Pi zeros and two
Raspberry Pi threes and we're gonna see
a diagram that will tell us a little bit
about what's going on in that
environment can we switch to the my demo
machine please there it is all right
very good so what I want to do is I
apologize could we go back to the slide
one for one minute there's a slide there
that I want to look at and I appreciate
the patience of the AV folks there there
we go sorry about that so this diagram
represents what's going on on the
raspberry PI's so we've got a an SP a
for an end that we'll see in just a
minute it's very very simple it's making
requests to some micronauts service
called the home controller that's
running on one of these raspberry PI's
and we've got four other raspberry PI's
that are all running copies of the same
service and those services are all
communicating with the database so SBA
talking to kind of a gateway service
that gateway service is communicating to
a number of services on the back end and
those backend services are communicating
with the database if we go back to the
demo machine again I would appreciate
that all right so this is the I need to
get connected to that Network all right
now if i refresh this page so this is
the s.p.a application and the data
that's being represented there is not
terribly interesting it's just a list of
company names you see OCI and Moga and
tesla there this is really the
interesting part the part that I want to
focus on and notice that that green box
the the for small raspberry PI's are
called MN PI 1 MN PI 2 MN PI 3 @ MN pi 4
and in the UI I can tell which of those
devices handled a particular request so
as I reload this page over and over and
over again
we're round-robin enthral all of those
back-end services so on that diagram
where you saw for company services we
round-robin anew all those services and
what I'm going to do right now is I just
unplugged one of them so I unplugged MN
PI 1
so now 2 3 & 4 are still operational but
Paiwan is down for maintenance or it's
crashed or for whatever reason it's it's
not operational right now and I'm able
to do that without interrupting the rest
of the system so I'm still round-robin
III the devices that request was handled
by number 4 that request was handled by
number 2 then 3 and then 4 so we just
took this guy out of the mix and the
rest of the system continues to behave
as as we would hope and I want to look
at a little bit of the code that's
involved in making that happen so if I
were to do this really pretty quickly
this is the HTTP client that's being
used in the front end to communicate
with the backend and notice on line 12
there where the app client annotation is
is the word companies what's happened is
all four of the company's services have
started up and registered themselves
with console our service discovery
engine that's running on one of the
devices so on the front end when I want
to communicate with those devices I've
annotated this interface with that
client companies and what will happen
when this client is initialized is is
micronaut will reach out to the service
discovery engine and find where are all
the company's services so it discovers
these four raspberry PI's dynamically
and it's round-robin III them on the
client side load balancing to
round-robin through all those devices
and then when one of them disappears the
round-robin just skips over one two four
one two four one two four right if
number three is out of the mix and I
don't have to write any of that code in
the application to take advantage of
that so here in my home controller this
is where the call this is in the front
end that's the call to the back end
there's no code here related to
round-robin aying there's no code here
related to retry logic I'm just saying
go get the companies from the back end
service and all of the complexity and
stuff that it takes to make that happen
is all handled inside of this HTTP
client so the client side load balancing
is built into this client the retry
logic is built into the client and now
my application code is kept very very
simple and it's very very easy to take
advantage of or get to
Communications to whatever is happening
in that and that back-end service right
hope all that makes sense I need to get
back on the public network now Google
next 2019 there we go all right so you
see the commands there that I executed
at the beginning of the session and now
if I go back to the front of the backend
again now we see Google next says hello
Jeff right that's evidence that we're
communicating with the version of the
service that I deployed at the beginning
of this talk and then if I go to send a
request to the front end we'll see that
the front end is communicating with that
updated instance of the back end right
so at the beginning of the session I
made a trivial code change and deployed
a new version of the service to GCP and
what it took to deploy that service the
GCP is basically the the Gradle config
that you saw in the slides earlier take
just a super quick look at that all
right so here's my back-end project in
my build dr. adel file I've got the App
Engine plugin added to the classpath I'm
applying the plug-in here and down here
somewhere right here is the code that
tells the plug-in what to do when I when
I asked it to deploy a back-end deploy
this service to GCP there's really
you've seen all the complexity involved
in deploying the micronaut services at
GCP this is all of it there's no there's
no pieces that I'm doing any hand waving
over so it's very very simple to build
and deploy micronauts services to GCP is
the bottom line
[Music]